السؤال مطروح الان
حقيقه يتعلق بقرار قاده الانقلاب تعليق
الاتفاق العسكري مع فرنسا ماذا انتم
فاعلون في الواقع ليس هناك تعاون امني
حاليا مع النيجر نحن لا نعترف الا بالسلطه
الشرعيه في نيجار اي الرئيس المنتخب
الديمقراطيا رئيس بازوم هناك تصميم صارم
من قبل رؤساء دولنا وحكوماتنا على وضع حد
للانقلابات وجعل النيجر مثالا على ذلك
للتاكد من اننا لن نسمح مره اخرى بتعطيل
تحرك المنطقه نحو ترسيخ الديمقراطيه ما هي
رؤيه فرنسا في كيفيه التعامل مع الوضع في
النيجر فرنسا او الاتحاد الاوروبي او
الولايات المتحده فنحن جميعا ندعم مجهود
تبذلها منظمه غرب افريقيا
لكي لا تنتشر مثل هذه الانقلاب بمجرد
مجموعه صغيره الكريم اخذوا الرئيس المنتخب
واعتقلوا الوزراء
واوقفوا الاحزاب واوقفوا المسائل الاعلام
وبالتالي هم يفرضون السلطه استبداديه في
النيجر اليوم اذا ما قرر قادت على القيام
بعمل عسكري هل ستدعم فرنسا هذا العمل
العسكري نصل هذه المرحله ونحن الان في هذا
الوقت الحالي علينا نقدر تماما انه لابد
ممارسه كل الضغوط المجتمع الدولي على
الانقلابين لكي لا نصل الى مثل هذه
الفرضيه وانتاج انها ستكون سهله او بدون
اراقه الدماء طائرات سيدمرون قصر الرئاسه
الذي يقعد في وسط العاصمه في احياء
السكنيه فلا ادري لاعادتي الى ديمقراطيه
او تحرير واحد مدمر لكل العاصمه او كيف
الله اعلم موقفنا قريب من موقف دول اخوه
ونحاول العوده الى الوضع سوري في النيجر
لابد ان للانقلابين اليوم ان يسمعوا رساله
المجتمع الدولي وهي رساله واضحه وهي
الدعوه الى تحليل الرئيس مرزوق عسكريون
ليس لهم تفكير في تراجع هذا غير وارد اصلا
في خطط
لانه وصلوا الى نقطه الى عوده قوات التي
اتخذتها مجموعه الاكواس قويه جدا
وتاثيراتها كبيره على النيجر قطعت
الكهرباء عنها وقطعت كل معاملات التجاريه
معها وايضا واعطاهم انذارا نهائيا بانه قد
يلجاون لاستخدام القوه